so as we said this Chinese spy balloon
came to the attention of most Americans
yesterday when it was spotted flying
over the state of Montana military base
a base with intercontinental ballistic
missiles now the Pentagon did not inform
the governor of Montana about it until
after the Boon was over Montana
so of course they would have known
because they've been tracking it since
it left China but they didn't tell Greg
gianforte who's the governor of that
state and repeated to be we can't say we
don't live there one of the best
governors in the country we're happy to
have him join us tonight Governor thank
you for coming on
um they knew it was coming over your
state you're the chief executive of your
state why didn't anyone tell you do you
think
well when I got briefed uh this
slow-moving balloon uh was hundreds of
miles into Montana it had already flown
near the Air Force Base and the ICBM
silos when I finally got informed it was
over our most populous city it got
spotted by a photographer at the airport
well that's that's bizarre I mean that
suggests deception of course if you're
the federal government you Alert state
governments you're the head of your
state government when something like
this happens do you have any sense what
the backstory could be here
you know I don't I just know Tucker if
it was up to montanans uh this thing
would have been taken out of the sky the
moment it entered our Sovereign airspace
and it clearly been there for a while
it's not moving that fast
yeah unfortunately 308 does not extend
to 60 000 feet so you really need some
kind of a missile why do you think so I
mean from that's where the question from
your perspective it's a pretty clear
case of we know what to do next shoot it
down why do you think they didn't
well I'm not sure initially in the
briefing I got earlier in the week they
were contemplating uh taking it out of
the sky for whatever reason they didn't
do that now clearly this went to the
president's desk he was given options
for whatever reason he chose not to act
and unfortunately the result of that is
that Americans are endangered and our
enemies are emboldened
amazing
um Governor I hate to pull random video
off the internet and ask you to respond
to it but this is going around it
appears to be it's on social media video
of an explosion over your state showing
what looks like a smoke Trail in to the
sky we can't even guess as to what this
is do you have any information about
this
I not at this point I was notified of it
just minutes before we came on the air
uh we're monitoring the situation I'm
talking to our uh National Guard to find
out if they have additional information
I'm sure I'll be briefed here in the
next hour
last question the explanation from as I
know you heard the administration is we
didn't shoot this down over Montana
because we feared
the wreckage would hurt people on the
ground in Montana but I hear you saying
as the governor of Montana you would
have shot it down so that's not that's
not a concern that would have prevented
you from acting
well well Tucker you've been to Montana
yeah eastern Montana is probably one of
the best places to take it down we could
have contained it we could have found
out what the mission truly was by
recovering whatever electronics are on
this balloon again if if the Americans
had flown a spy balloon over China do
you think it'd still be in the air of
course not we should have taken action
unfortunately we've emboldened our enemy
today that is exactly right and that's
it's such a smart Point Governor I
appreciate your coming on tonight thank
you
my pleasure
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight